WORST OF THE WORST.
SIT DOWN, BUCKLE UP, IT'S TIME
FOR TONIGHT'S BREAKING NEWS
SINGAPORE OPENING MONOLOGUE.
IT'S 9:00 A.M. AND SINGAPORE AT
9:00 P.M. IN THE NATION'S
CAPITAL.
IN LESS THAN 20 BARS, THE DOJ'S
WATCHDOG IS SCHEDULED TO RELEASE
THIS ALL-IMPORTANT IG
REPORT.
18 MONTHS WE HAVE BEEN WAITING.
AS WE SPEAK, WE HAVE A TEAM OF
EXPERTS LINED UP THAT WILL BE
ANALYZING THE 500-PLUS PAGES IN
THE REPORT LINE BY LINE, AND WE
WILL BREAK IT ALL DOWN I
PROMISE, AS SOON AS WE GET IT.
TONIGHT, PRESSURE FROM ROD
ROSENSTEIN AND OTHER
OBSTRUCTIONIST BUREAUCRATS IN
THE DOJ.
THIS IMPENDING REPORT SHOULD
SHED A CRITICAL LIGHT ON WHAT
WERE THE CRIMES OF
HILLARY CLINTON AND HOW THE FBI,
DOJ, HIGH-RANKING MEMBERS OF THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION COMPLETELY
AND INTENTIONALLY FIXED, BOTCHED
THE CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
OF COURSE, THE CONTENTS OF THE
REPORT COULD BE TOTALLY RUINED
BY ROD ROSENSTEIN AND HIS
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
REMEMBER, THIS REPORT COULD BE
VERY EMBARRASSING FOR ALL OF
THEM.
TONIGHT WE ARE ASKING THE
QUESTIONS.
WILL THEY REPORT INCLUDE MASSIVE
REDACTIONS?
WAS THE REPORT ALTERED BY THE
UPPER ECHELON OF THE DOJ?
WERE MICHAEL HOROWITZ'S FINDINGS
TWISTED, PARSED, OR ALTERED IN
ANY WAY?
WE WILL HAVE A FULL REPORT
TOMORROW.
THE FACTS AREN'T IN DISPUTE.
LOOK AT THE SIDE OF THE SCREEN.
HILLARY CLINTON, WE KNOW, FACT,
IRREFUTABLE VIOLATED 18 USC 793,
ESPIONAGE ACT.
SHE MISHANDLED, DESTROYED
CLASSIFIED TOP SECRET SPECIAL
ACCESS PROGRAMMING INFORMATION.
IT'S A FACT.
SHE DELETED 33,000 SUBPOENAED
EMAILS.
18 USC 2071.
SHE ACID WASHED FOR HARD DRIVE
WITH BLEACH BIT.
THAT'S A FACT.
SHE DESTROYED LITERALLY, HAD
AIDS DESTROY, OR MOBILE DEVICES
WITH A HAMMER.
THAT'S A FACT.
A YEAR IN PRISON FOR SIX
PICTURES OF A SUBMARINE.
WE KNOW THAT COMEY AND PETER
STRZOK, THEY STARTED WRITING THE
EXONERATION OF HILLARY IN EARLY
MAY OF 2016 BUT THEY DIDN'T
INTERVIEW HER AND 17 OTHER
WITNESSES UNTIL EARLY JULY AND
THREE DAYS LATER, THEY
EXONERATED HER.
WE KNOW THEY PULLED OUT THE
LEGAL DEFINITION OF GROSS
NEGLIGENCE AND PULLED OUT BEFORE
AND INTEL AGENCIES LIKELY HACKED
INTO THE SERVER.
THAT'S A FACT.
DEVELOPING STORY WE'VE GOT TO
TELL YOU ABOUT.
DEPUTY AG, THERE YOU SEE ON THE
SCREEN, ROD ROSENSTEIN.
ACCORDING TO REPORTING FROM
CATHERINE HERRIDGE, THE DEPUTY
AG OF THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA ACTUALLY THREATENED TO
SUBPOENA THE EMAILS AND OTHER
RECORDS OF SEVERAL REPUBLICAN
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS AND THEIR
STAFFS.
AND AFTER LOSING HIS TEMPER
WHICH ACCORDING TO MULTIPLE
SOURCES I KNOW, HE FREQUENTLY
DOES, HE LAUNCHED INTO WHAT WAS
DESCRIBED AS A PERSONAL ATTACK
AGAINST A CONGRESSIONAL STAFFER.
THIS ALL CAME AFTER THE HOUSE
INTEL COMMITTEE RAMPED UP ITS
OVERSIGHT EFFORTS SURROUNDING
MULTIPLE DOJ LED TO
INVESTIGATIONS IN JANUARY.
IN OTHER WORDS, LET ME MAKE THIS
CLEAR.
ROD ROSENSTEIN WAS TRYING TO
BULLY, INTIMIDATE, THREATEN
HOUSE REPUBLICAN, HOUSE INTEL
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN AND THEIR
MEMBERS FROM FOLLOWING AND DOING
THEIR CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY OF
OVERSIGHT.
WE HAVE IN THE SYSTEM IN OUR
COUNTRY CHECKS AND BALANCES,
SEPARATION OF POWERS.
IT'S ACTUALLY CALLED THE
U.S. CONSTITUTION.
BY THE WAY, YOU SHOULD AND I
WILL CALL IT PROPER HASSLE THAT
ANYBODY IN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WOULD EVER USE THEIR
POWER OR THREATEN TO USE THEIR
POWER IS AMERICA'S DEFECT
OUT OF LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIAL
TO LITERALLY INTIMIDATE MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS.
FORMER CHIEF ASSISTANT U.S.
ATTORNEY AFTER McCARTNEY
SUMMED IT UP, "ROD ROSENSTEIN'S
SUBPOENA THREAT, HE'S CONFLICTED
AND HE'S ACTING LIKE IT."
HARVARD LAW PROFESSOR ALAN
WATCH THIS.
>> THIS IS A CLASSIC DISPUTE
BETWEEN SEPARATION OF POWERS.
THE LEGISLATURE HAS THE POWER
OBVIOUSLY TO OVERSEE AN
INVESTIGATION, INVESTIGATE THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
A MEMBER OF THE EXECUTIVE
BRANCH, WHAT ROD ROSENSTEIN IS,
SHOULDN'T BE ABLE TO BULLY THE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH.
HE SHOULD BE TRANSPARENT.
HE SHOULD TURN OVER THE
DOCUMENTS.
HE SHOULD BE COOPERATIVE AND
CONGRESS SHOULD BE OPERATIVE OF
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH.
>> Sean: PROFESSOR DERSHOWITZ
IS 1000% RATE.
JONATHAN TURLEY.
HE'S ALSO SLAMMING ROD
ROSENSTEIN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK THE THREAT, FOR A
CIVIL SUBPOENA, WAS RECKLESS.
HE SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE THAT.
HE IS SUBJECT TO THE OVERSIGHT
OF THE HOUSE AND SENATE
COMMITTEES.
THESE COMMITTEES HAVE A HISTORY
OF RATHER POOR OVERSIGHT.
FOR THOSE OF US WHO HAVE ARGUED
FOR YEARS THAT THESE COMMITTEES
NEED TO EXERCISE REAL OVERSIGHT,
DEMAND DOCUMENTS ARE NOT BACK
DOWN, THIS IS A REFRESHING
TREND.
THE ALLEGATIONS THAT ONE PARTY
USED THE FBI TO INVESTIGATE THE
OPPOSING PARTY, IT'S ONE OF THE
MOST SERIOUS MATTERS FOR
OVERSIGHT IN OUR SYSTEM.
IT GOES TO THE VERY HEART OF OUR
ELECTORAL SYSTEM AND OUR
GOVERNMENTAL SYSTEM.
THERE IS EVERY REASON FOR THE
MEMBERS TO WANT TO SEE THESE
DOCUMENTS.
>> Sean: SOME MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS, THEY ARE ALSO FIRING
BACK.
CONGRESSMAN GOWDY AND MEADOWS
REVEALED THE RESOLUTION CALLING
OUT ROD ROSENSTEIN FOR HIS
THREATS TO SUBPOENA.
OF COURSE IT ALL COMES IN THE
SHADOW OF THE RAMPANT
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE THAT WE
KNOW HAS BEEN GOING ON WITH THE
DOJ NOT WILLING TO HAND OVER
DOCUMENTS.
INCLUDING SPECIFIC OHIO'S FROM
THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE
CHAIRMAN DEVIN NUNES OVER
DOCUMENTS SURROUNDING THE FBI'S
USE OF INFORMANTS IN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
NUNES SET A DEADLINE FOR
YESTERDAY.
THE DOJ IGNORED IT.
ROD ROSENSTEIN, WHAT ARE YOU
HIDING?
WHY ARE YOU OBSTRUCTING,
INTIMIDATING, THREATENING,
HARASSING CONGRESSIONAL MEMBERS
AND THEIR STAFF?
IT IS TIME FOR ROD ROSENSTEIN TO
STEP ASIDE OR BE FIRED BECAUSE
IF THIS IS AN ATTEMPT AT
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE, WHY
WON'T YOU LET CONGRESS DO THEIR
JOB?
ACCORDING TO NEW POLITICAL POLL
NUMBERS, MUELLER'S PUBLIC IMAGE,
ROD ROSENSTEIN APPOINTED
MUELLER, AT AN ALL-TIME LOW.
PEOPLE BEGINNING TO UNDERSTAND.
EAP REPORTING MUELLER STEAM IS
"WORRIED THAT RUSSIAN
INTELLIGENCE SERVICES WILL USE A
CRIMINAL CASE IN WASHINGTON TO
GATHER ABOUT ITS INVESTIGATION
AND U.S. INTELLIGENCE GATHERING
METHODS."
WE WILL HAVE MORE ON THAT.
THEY NEVER SHOULD'VE FILED THOSE
TONIGHT, I HOPE YOU CAN STOMACH
THIS.
YOU ARE MAINSTREAM, CORRUPT
MEDIA, THE DESTROY TRUMP MEDIA
HAS REACHED A NEW LOW.
DESPITE SO MUCH SUCCESS AT HOME
ON THE ECONOMY AND ABROAD, NOT
INCLUDING THIS WEEK HERE IN
SINGAPORE, THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN OVERWHELMINGLY PORTRAYED
NEGATIVELY IN THE PRESS.
EARLIER TODAY, THE PRESIDENT IS
FIGHTING BACK.
HE TWEETED:
"SO FUNNY TO WATCH THE
FAKE NEWS, ESPECIALLY NBC
AND CNN.
THEY ARE FIGHTING HARD TO
DOWNPLAY THE DEAL WITH NORTH
KOREA.
500 DAYS AGO THEY WOULD HAVE
"BEGGED" FOR THIS DEAL.
LOOKED LIKE WAR WOULD BREAK OUT.
OUR COUNTRY'S BIGGEST ENEMY
IS THE FAKE NEWS SO EASILY
PROMULGATED BY FOOLS!"
NOW THE PRESIDENT IS RIGHT, AND
HERE'S ALL THE PROOF YOU WILL
EVER NEED.
YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
THEY CALL THEMSELVES NEWSPEOPLE.
IT'S PATHETIC.
A BUNCH OF LAZY, OVERPAID
SO-CALLED COLLEAGUES, AND THEY
HAVE A RADICAL LEFT-WING AGENDA.
IT'S OBVIOUS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> USUALLY WHEN TRUMP SIGNS AN
AGREEMENT WITH A FOREIGNER, IT'S
A PRENUP.
>> ALMOST CAVEMAN LIKE.
IT REALLY IS.
COUNTRY.
WRITING THINGS ON STONE, NOT
EVEN ABLE TO DO THAT.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID
KIM JONG UN IS ABSOLUTELY
INVITED TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
YEAH.
UNLESS OF COURSE KIM JONG UN
WINS THE SUPER BOWL OR THE NBA
CHAMPIONSHIP.
>> WHY THE PRAISES?
WE ALL TALK ABOUT A CASE LIKE
THAT, THE LANGUAGE.
IT'S OUTRAGEOUS THE WAY HE
TALKS.
THIS GUY IS A KILLER.
>> A LOT OF THE REASON WE WERE
ON THE BRINK OF NUCLEAR WAR, TO
BE SURE, THE NEW -- NUCLEAR
TESTS AND THE RECKLESS AND
IRRESPONSIBLE RHETORIC FROM
DONALD TRUMP RATCHETING UP
TENSIONS.
THIS IS THE ARSONIST GETTING
CREDIT FOR PUTTING OUT THE FIRE.
>> TO BELIEVE KIM JONG UN IS
GOING TO GIVE AWAY HIS NUCLEAR
ARSENAL WHICH REALLY GIVES THE
POWER, I THINK WE WENT TOO FAR.
>> JUST BECAUSE SOMETHING HASN'T
HAPPENED BEFORE DOESN'T MEAN
IT'S HISTORIC.
THAT'S ONE THING.
I THINK WHEN YOU CALL SOMETHING
HISTORIC, IT MEANS IT HAS A GOOD
CHANCE OF HAVING LASTING
IMPLICATIONS.
I THINK IT'S VERY UNCLEAR, AT
LEAST TO MY LAYMAN'S EYE, THAT
THIS DOES THAT.
>> ANY PREVIOUS PRESIDENT COULD
HAVE EASILY HAD A SUMMIT WITH
ANY PREVIOUS LEADER WITH
NORTH KOREA BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN
VERY EAGER TO BE LEGITIMATED BY
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
DONALD TRUMP IS THE FIRST ONE TO
AGREE TO DO THAT.
>> Sean: MEANWHILE, OVER AT
MSNBC, THE CONSPIRACY THEORISTS
CHOICE AND CABLE NEWS, YOU HAVE
LIBERAL MORNING HOST, JOE
SCARBOROUGH, TRASHING
REPUBLICANS WHO SUPPORT THE
REPUBLICAN COMMANDER IN CHIEF.
SHOCKING.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> IN THE REPUBLICAN PARTY HAVE
DEVOLVED INTO A TRUMPIST CULT.
>> IT IS A CULT OF PERSONALITY.
THAT'S A GOOD DESCRIPTION.
>> Sean: THE ONLY CULT OF THE
PEOPLE WHO WATCH THAT RIDICULOUS
MORNING SHOW OF YOURS.
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP DOES.
IT DOESN'T MATTER HOW SUCCESSFUL
HIS AGENDA BECOMES OR HOW MUCH
THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, FORGOTTEN MEN
AND WOMEN, BECOMES.
THE MEDIA IN THIS COUNTRY IS
BLINDED BY PATHOLOGICAL HATRED
OF THIS PRESIDENT, SO MUCH SO
THAT IT'S NOW OUTWEIGHING THEIR
DESIRE EVEN FOR A ROBUST ECONOMY
AND PEACE IN THE WORLD.
THIS IS SICK.
THE RESIDENT IS ACTIVELY,